[Music]
you studied dance as a child is that
correct yeah what studied I don't know
if I'd say study I did recreational
dancing you just dance around right you
know I would compete but most kids did
but I yeah I I was really into dancing
but I was very skinny and gangly um as a
child and so all the other girls had
kind of developed a lot sooner than me
and so the costumes always fit really
awkwardly and we had a lot of fun I
think I brought some you have some
photos of you as a child when you were
in your dancing yeah oh my god oh my god
I'm so angry at that kid right now
everybody home by car like that I kept
on my Timex watch yeah okay it's a
musical I don't want to see and then
what okay oh there's a lot of you why do
you keep doing that spenders were never
a cool thing okay but also if you notice
in that photo my eyes are closed
yeah that was before digital so you got
one shot with the film camera right and
I love that background against brain
matter I think we have another
photograph there you can just keep safe
into the fray your arms are incredibly
long yeah gangly mess yeah that was
supposed to be a tight costume you can
tell his bunching in my stomach because
it was loose yeah but yeah I had very
very very long limbs yeah you know what
I do too I think we have a lot in common
we've established we're both very pale
very pale we're both very tall with long
limbs I think you are the female me I'll
take it really yeah I think I'm the
female me
you